Oh
[Music]
so it used to be that a sign of
prosperity was being given more choices
right freedom meant the freedom to
choose right but what happens when we
become victims of our own success right
now nowadays there's so many signals
competing for our attention that it's
been said if you don't have a DD today
you're not paying attention we're all
kind of suffering through this paralysis
of choice this bandwidth anxiety this
fracture attention spans because we go
to the supermarket and there is just too
much to pick from there's too many
options we lack the RAM to process all
these possibilities we experience
instead the angst of FOMO the angst that
no matter what we choose we are missing
out on something else and so the
exhilaration the prosperity of choice
the prosperity of freedom has become
oppressive right it's become the
paralysis of choice and so what then is
the future of design what kind of new
software platforms and new interfaces
between South and the world right and
what we consume are we going to create
that don't overwhelm us but that instead
induce flows that reduce friction right
the best technology reduces friction
let's let's you choose something and
then gets out of the way if so I read an
article recently a vast company that
says that the future of design is
anticipatory choice right it's this
notion that we're going to Oslo
decisions to algorithms that are gonna
know us better than we know ourselves so
that when we walk upon the world options
will be afforded to us and offered to us
only when intuitively when intuitively
make sense
we will never be bombarded by too much
things we'll just open up like a garden
of forking pads everything will be
engaging and delivered to us and a
dosage that we can process so it'll be
like being in the flow when you're not
really lacking anything and the right
thing is served up to your frontal lobe
when useful and read it but it'll never
be running around a crowded city
overwhelmed by follow and dying from
inside and because of the anxiety so I
actually think that this is going to be
kind of Awesome I mean some people are
scared it's gonna create idiocracy and
we're all gonna be numbed into stupor
but I don't so I think we're all going
to be and delivered
universes that extend your imagination
to spaces and places and virtuality is
we cannot even imagine I think the games
are gonna get better and I think we're
going to offload ourselves into the
games we're going to live inside of our
imaginations and things will be served
up to us as limited when needed and
it'll be amazing we're all gonna be of
this amazing heroes a journey that's
gonna be great we won't be weighed down
by RAM or stupid decisions they're
stupid options
[Music]